this is why i tell guys do not feed
women before you before you smash them
do not
feed women before you smash never feed
her before you [ __ ] her wow hold on
what did you just
listen what did she just say not 30
seconds ago i'm trying to get my free
email but hold on let me finish 30
listen there was a survey out and
everybody knows about this there was a
there was a survey and i probably think
the number is even bigger than that 30
of women admitted that they are on
dating apps strictly to get fed there
are there are women oh yeah i could
afford a burger whatever you got but
hold on why because
listen i'm sure many girls can afford
dinners but why pay when you can just
when you can finesse a sucker into
women 30 of women are on dating apps
they go out with men they have no sexual
interest in unbeknownst to the man
strictly for the free meal yeah
this is documented you can go you can go
to reading go this i gotta pull up a
story go ahead but keep going devon do
you wanna wait i tell guys this is why i
tell guys to to shield from giving out
free meals for for just your attention
and company before you don't want to get
out of sex
before they have sex never feed her
before you smash her
hold on hold on real quick real quick
only men with options can do this if i
have options okay cool if you're not
going to get me
no problem that means i'm not for you
you're not for me i've got other options
men who don't men who have men who have
options are able to have that standard
men who don't have that options are not
able to enforce them all men are not
created equal that's exactly all women
damn right devin
did he buy you dinner before there was a
smash or how did he did is is what he's
saying true did he take you out for
drinks how did it work oh i was cooking
him dinner before he ever bought me at
dinner that's for sure okay uh
it's funny with the with this thing like
with traffic or yeah travis kelsey we
always get to mix it up don't we yes we
do um there is a disparity between what
they earn but it's
you have to take into consideration
travis would be a psychopath if he said
hey honey we're gonna i'm going on a
european vacation it's gonna cost me
forty thousand dollars if you wanna come
you got to come up with 40 grand
i don't think that they're making these
types of plans to basically you know
bankrupt this woman so if if it's her
idea to go out and he's like okay you
pay this time i'll pay next time that's
that's a standard that he set up that's
something that she accepted for her to
all of a sudden to say oh no now you're
making way more money than i am yep uh
you should be paying well no honey that
wasn't the standard that was set up when
they started dating so it shouldn't
necessarily change
um you know and honestly she shouldn't
be trying to live a lifestyle that she
can't afford to sustain there it is uh
and that just shows that you're
financially making bad decisions and i
think if it shows that if you're going
to be a good significant other you're
going to want to make
uh you're going to want to make uh good
financial decisions and know that one
day if she's responsible for half for
your bank account as well she's not
going to be planning 50 000 european
vacations without letting you know ahead
of time okay so by the way this is what
we're talking about right here thank you
for pulling us up dining out i was low
on cash in college so i went on 16 dates
in a row to eat my confession has left
people divided please scroll down this
is essentially we're talking about this
don't take them out
before you smash one tick doctor shared
how she was able to
she got meals while running low on cash
and it's upsetting many people she
claimed she went on 16 dinner dates in a
row when she ran out of money since the
dates would pay for her dinner in
college i ran out of food for money and
a girl's gotta eat pretty girl nice eyes
there we go
okay it's not pretty okay you don't hold
that body what's that body do with that
mouth doodle well some people call her a
genius others say she was using
men janita
you said you want your free meals do you
condone what this young lady's doing no
i don't
when i say i want my free meals okay
these are people that i am going out on
dates with because i want to go out with
them not because
oh if i go out with this fugly guy that
i have no interest in whatsoever he's
gonna feed me oh my
i've never been god
desperate in my [ __ ] life like you
know what i'm saying no so that part of
things i don't condone and i kind of
feel like it gives
a really bad
it leaves a bad taste in in guys
literally
yes
yeah it leaves a really bad taste in
guys mal's about
going there and and being that for a
woman and oh i'm gonna take out the
dinner oh no i could take this [ __ ] out
then because she might be using me i
ain't gonna get no [ __ ] i don't know
what to you know
you know she you know she gonna block me
after i you know pay for the bill all
this stuff so i can understand that part
to some degree
because i'm not saying it doesn't happen
sure it happens absolutely okay there's
some
you know gutter snipes everybody snipes
gutter snake you got to be a lobby she's
not an exception to the rule adam this
happens a lot and you want to know
something i actually condone this
behavior you do i dude i condone it 100
men need to men gotta understand the way
women really are
the world is telling men that women are
made of sugar spice and everything nice
women know that they're made of anything
but that's not a good thing but that's
not a bad thing either what women are
referring to hold on
let me let me let me know well here's
the thing women are neither good nor bad
you just are men we're not inherently
good we're not inherently evil we just
are there is no morality in the jungle
the lionesses don't slut-shame lioness
number two because she smashed the alpha
uh the lionesses don't get jealous of
each other because they're smashed in
the same alpha that's how it is one lion
propagates alert
probably gets a herd of six lionesses
one lioness doesn't take the loads of
five alpha males that's just not the way
it works and so
in the same vein
men have to understand they have to
understand especially with content like
this that there are women out there who
will take advantage of you if you let
them buy the same token men also take
advantage of women so this woman is
getting praised for going out with men
that she is not romantically involved in
strictly for getting fed not mad at that
but then when you get guys like the
diamond dash dater or guys who get sex
out of women before they feed women with
no intention of committing to them now
we're called misogynists we're called
womenators so wait a minute so you
condone a woman leveraging her sexuality
for resources but we can't leverage our
resources for sexuality like like she
like she's giving the impression that
she's sexually interested but not really
we're giving the impression that we're
relationship interested but not really
it is literally the same thing the
difference is men are shame for it women
are praised for it final thoughts right
here and i'll go to you this is just
scratching the surface on how diabolical
oh god you absolutely is because this
woman is taking her leftovers home to
the guy that she is today
i have done this before i have done this
but when i was in vegas at the height of
my vegas powers i used to do this for my
friends and be like watch this there's a
girl named lindsay used to bang she had
a boyfriend three year boyfriend i said
watch this he took her to outback or
something like that i said watch this
bring me back a bloomin onion and
kookaburra wings no way 10 30 at night
she went out on a date with out on a
date with this guy she moved up the date
so that she could smash me later on
true to form she brought home she
brought home outback uh
uh bloomin onion and kookaburra wings
the dude that she was with had no idea
that she was feeding the guy she was
[ __ ] after she got done using him
damn this is what women do and it's it
and it is what it is man
women only do what you allow them to do
and i can't blame and it's not i'm not
con well i don't want to say that i
condone this behavior but what we have
to understand this is why i teach money
muscles game and frame if you have your
mind right women like this will not they
can't take advantage of you so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauce cast click right here
you